can i say what i agreed with you oman
[Laughter]
i here this is the clip this is
this is the clip i mean i agree about
nations so i i don't like the term
nationalism because i i fear of what
happens when you put in ism at the end
of any anywhere anything yes but but the
nation is is a good thing that and and
having a diversity of nations in a sense
it's a good thing and in this sense
in this sense i don't think one can come
up so
look i i i said i hold that the ideal
nation is a nation that protects
individual rights
how do you do that
what are the details how do we define
property rights exactly in an internet
world there's going to be disagreement
rational reasonable disagreement they're
going to be in in my
future in the 300 years from now when my
ideas have won finally right there will
be multiple nations trying to apply the
principle of applying individual rights
and they'll do it differently one of the
one of the benefits of federalism
is that while you have a national
government there are certain issues that
you relegate to states and they can try
different things and learn because there
is a huge value in the empirical
knowledge comes there you can't just
deduce it all and figure it all out you
have to experiment so i do
i hate the idea of a one-world na one
world government because
experimentation is gone and if you make
a mistake everybody suffers i like the
idea and then i like the idea of people
being able to to choose
where they live but but this notion of
experimentation i think is crucial but
you need a principle this is you need a
principle so i don't like the idea of
nations if all the nations are going to
be
bad right if all the nations are going
to be horrible then i don't like it what
i like is a variety of nations all
practicing
basically good ideas and then we try to
figure out okay what works better than
other things and and and what is
sustainable and what is not
you